good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Wednesday oh my God it
is hump day don't forget to hump someone
you it's also merch launch day which is
so exciting
we are wearing inverted crew necks from
the career next we wore yesterday I'm
wearing toasty lights in pink Claudia is
wearing white I was wondering like can
we wear our pajamas on the show because
we need to promote them and okay let's
talk about that just but then we're
sitting here pajamas
no I mean who [ __ ] cares about that
at least you're in your house like I
would have to get in an Uber in my
pajamas which is mortifying but not
something I'm above
um personally I was gonna wear my
pajamas today but when I tell you the
black ones I've been wearing like three
nights in a row like they're officially
due for a wash and I was not gonna put
on the white ones and show my legs on
the podcast so I was left with no choice
but to model this gorgeous white crew
neck from toastmerch.com
understood okay so I have I have license
to wear pajamas on the show that's
exciting maybe I'll wait until Friday
it's like a little crazy and I feel like
if people don't know we're launching
merch and they just see these girls in
their pajamas
here's the thing first of all I don't
think it's that crazy second of all like
really we're now making decisions based
on what people will think no but like if
we're trying to attract new viewers and
then they're like these girls
if I stumbled across a podcast for two
Fabulous Girls we're sitting wearing
gorgeous well-made perfect button-sized
pajamas I would say you know what these
girls they've got Charisma that's what I
would say okay I mean not everyone is as
open-minded as you
that's so true actually like I really am
kind of like ahead of my time you're so
open-minded open to trying new things
never someone to just say no to
something just cause
that's not you no and like stubborn is
not a word I don't think anyone would
use to define me antonym antonym it's
giving antonym
antonym yeah no they would never they
could never
um so our holiday collection has
officially launched at toastmerch.com
you can shop all of our new apparel
which is crewnecks pajamas you can shop
our accessories for Holiday we've got
mugs blankets slippers
um it's really a stunning collection we
have ornaments the ornaments always sell
out really quick
um I guess we're big in the Christian
and Catholic communities that's just us
like Jewish Queens like
um
and it's just a fabulous time to be a
toaster toastmarch.com it is limited
inventory we have a lot of inventory but
not unlimited so make sure you head over
to toastmerch.com get everything you
want for you if you want to send this
episode to the man or woman in your life
to buy it for you
oh
that's a good idea we have P John P jow
slippers I believe they're one size
um so if you've got like an extra big
foot I don't know if it's maybe shy away
maybe this isn't the product for you I
don't know if it's gonna happen for you
I don't is it one size yeah and for me
like the slippers they're they are they
fit nicely there's definitely Room to
Grow
um but I'm a size seven and I fit really
nicely in them but um but the thing is
we are constantly encouraging room to
grow so it's really on brand for us yeah
yeah but I just like want to say like if
you've got a Bigfoot like I don't I'm
just one if you got a Bigfoot let me
check out our mugs
but like they are like a very average
size because I have a really nice
there's space yeah there's space their
average size so I would say if your foot
is bigger or smaller than average I just
want to give you a heads up because I
feel like if I was a big footed toaster
and I got them like I'd be kind of
annoyed I would say you know Jackie and
Claudia don't support the Bigfoot
community and you would be right about
that so again maybe check out some of
the other offerings at toastmerch.com
yeah this one is not for you not for you
um so it's hump day I'm sure everyone
already knows what's on the agenda hump
someone you love Fast Five into your
toasters and we have some really
interesting deer toasters today that I
do think will pose
um some some interesting dialogue great
can't wait also did you see that update
about last week's deer toasters in the
toast after dark Facebook group yes
about the girl whose cousin who was like
16 was pregnant yeah so
long story short she was lying yeah
she's just like a big liar it's giving
Paul Giamatti big fat liar he's just
like looking she's like a troubled she's
a troubled teen who is making things up
for attention and it's obviously not
about that it's there's something deeper
going on with it so thank you to
everyone who put in their two cents
um but I feel like everybody wasn't
needed everyone should know that update
and not like worry about what the 16
year old's gonna do like there's nothing
to be done yeah it wasn't needed it was
we were the girl who wrote in was
stooped as we're away as a community as
were we as we're the bigfooted toasters
the bft are we by the way we're going to
be one of those podcasts that like talks
about Bigfoot but like not the the scary
dog that lives in the woods today's
episode is an expose on Bigfoot and why
you should imagine slippers
from shopmorningtoast.com from
toto.com
still works because that really rolls
off the tongue after years it is going
to take some adjusting for me to like be
my promo girly and not automatically go
shopmoneytoast.com yeah I understand oh
so wait I have to tell you I um I went
to two of me and Ben's Friends got
engaged last night and they had like
obviously like we were all waiting after
they got engaged it was really cute and
fun and I met I feel like you wouldn't
appreciate this but a lot of The
Toasters will and the person who
appreciated it the most is Olivia's
husband Zach Shapiro because I send him
a picture of me and this girl and he is
obsessed so and I feel like I've quoted
her on the podcast before
um
yeah oh how do you know that I follow
Erica she's a lawyer who reads a fine
print that's why I follow her
um she's like honestly like a tick tock
I icon
so I went up to her and I was like
that's why I follow Erica she reads a
fine print so I don't have to and she
was like living for my energy That's so
exciting
and I sent a picture of me and her to
Zach Shapiro and like he was StarStruck
on my behalf
it was amazing
glorious congrats to your friends
thank you yeah it was a nice night
um I'm exhausted Monday and Tuesday I
woke up at 4 00 a.m that's like not
something I do but you know I did what I
had to do to get back to New York on
Monday yesterday I went on television to
like talk about my hour like expanding
booming business
multi-billion dollar industry
um
and so last night I went to bed at 10
and I woke up at nine today and when I
tell you I'd feel
worse no sometimes I've actually been
getting I don't want to jinx it but like
decent sleep because
Harry's like pretty much going all the
way now and
I'm more tired than ever
so I have recently very sadly come to
the conclusion because for years I have
prioritized sleep like I will say no to
many different things because it
interferes with my weekday sleep
um and I recently came to the very sad
conclusion that I might have been
missing out on things for the last
couple of years for no reason because I
think I think I'm getting too much sleep
there
too much sleep like but I do think that
going out versus having like a relaxing
night in and then going to sleep at a
normal hour like is you do feel more
energized the other night I stayed up
till 2 A.M and the next day I was not
well
oh my God what were you doing you crazy
teenager until 2 A.M I had some friends
over and it like wasn't even crazy we
were just like chit-chatting all night
long and they were at my house girls
night one girl's night like Mom's Night
in it was crazy
mni mni so like the next day like I was
literally trying to it was worse than
ever so it does make a difference but
then this weekend there were a few
nights where I got like
some nice chunky sleep and I'm still so
tired so I think I'm just like the
science of sleep is very interesting I'm
just meant to be tired
I think I'm just meant to be asleep
actually I've been noticing my energy
levels like of course when I wake up
like I am don't talk to me but like
throughout the day I'm I'm not I'm not
like so tired right now I just need to
chug this
yeah I just feel as though there's
definitely a lot of research on the
science of sleep and it would definitely
behoove me to look into it because I
think I'm doing it all wrong I think
that you should give your fortune to
sleep research because there's not
enough of it and we need answers it is
such a big part of life sleeping is
literally 50 of the 8 billion people's
activity no and I like I always am
hearing about like
but different successful people like
going on podcasts and talking about
their sleep habits how they've like
discovered the perfect thing for them
the amount of hours what to do before
bed and I really need to get in tune
with my body because like I'm really
sick of being tired you know and you
think I'm annoying and energetic now I'm
operating at seriously 50 you know what
you need
let me think
what do I need an or a ring
to let you know to let you know about
your sleep
because let me tell you about you I
don't think that's in depth enough like
I need an actual team of scientists to
study my body like for real
I need Elon Elon is the only because
Elon when Elon went on Joe Rogan and Joe
Rogan was asking him about his sleep
because I guess like a lot of successful
like very smart people have unique
sleeping habits and Elon was like I
honestly I sleep six hours and Joe Rogan
was like well that seems like a lot for
like a crazy genius you know yeah and he
was like no I tried the whole four-hour
thing and I was tired so I started
sleeping more it was extremely rational
um so by that logic I'm always tired I
need to be sleeping more but when I tell
you like I for the last like literally
for the last five years on the weekdays
I prioritize sleep so much like I am in
bed no later than nine o'clock let's be
real I'm in bed since like six no but
you lights out Tick-Tock down at what
time
seriously 10 30 maybe 11. like I really
am very good about that and you know I
have the luxury of Designing my own life
I'm a business owner so I wake up at 8
30 9. that's a lot of [ __ ] sleep that
might be too much sleep but I agree that
a lot of successful people like don't
sleep
well I think right but they also put the
and they find themselves energized they
find themselves energized but also like
that gives them more hours in the day to
do be successful things
right but there is something in this
successful Community about sleep that we
haven't that us lay people haven't been
told yet no I'm telling you the
successful the elite class in this
country is holding on to information
they are keeping secrets from the lay
people about how to be like the
perfectly balanced sleeper do you think
that they also maybe have drugs that
um give them no like you know like the
movie Limitless
no I don't think so because big Pharma
is like so obsessed with like monetizing
on Pharmaceuticals if there was like a
miracle drug
would capitalize it like big pharma's
Capital link is right now on that shot
that everyone's taking to lose weight
like they're capitalizing on the moment
the diabetes shrugs
um right if there was something out
there but wait hold on counter thought
if there was something out there that
could make so many people so smart and
successful that would actually
ultimately Fringe on big pharma's
margins because there would be medium
Pharma small Pharma you know Boutique
Pharma and ultimately I think that they
would lose market share
so you're saying by giving access to
this Limitless drug big Pharma has a lot
to lose therefore they're not giving
access to it yes I think so
no that's that's something to think
about for sure it is something to think
not us deconstructing big Pharma it's
all in a day's work here at the toast
oh so is the Fast Five and dear toasters
which we're gonna get into and what
should be another fabulous day of being
The Toasters unless you're a bft in
which case not your day I'm so sorry
it's not it's not a great day to be a
Bigfoot toaster let's just say that but
but other days are really good days to
be bigfooted toasters because it's like
sizes that most people don't buy so you
can usually get the style that you want
in your size it's really exciting you
know if you have a very common average
foot size you're clamoring with
everybody else for the latest trends I
guess what we're trying to say here is
bigfooted toasters we see you we love
you we stand with you but just slightly
far away because your feet are so damn
big
I have a question on a woman what do you
think is like a nine no
no nine is is like
I feel like a nine is like a six you
know on the
crazy but see this is what's so [ __ ]
up about Society like if you have a size
six which is like a little bit below
average you're like oh yeah she has a
size six it's so cute if you have a size
nine which is like a little bit above
average oh you're a bigfooted cloud hop
[ __ ] like you're like a good
like a giant no but I would say like a
six is still in the range of normal food
and so is nine yeah no I think when you
enter the double digits things get a
little a little hairy a little dicey and
maybe you could try men's
you could try Sears yeah
no that's an interesting question what
size are you I am a six and a half seven
depending on if it's a shoe that uses a
sock or am I barefooted in it does the
brand run bigger are you the Barefoot
Contessa like on in a flat I'm a six and
a half because there's no extra room but
in a boot oh I need a bigger boot I
can't get like a stop yeah I'm like I'm
the same thing one size up I'm like a
seven and a half eight because I'm like
so perfectly average in every single way
you're so average sized in every sense
I'm just so average
it's really like underrated
I completely agree I don't love that
phrase and just like that General
sentiment like why fit in when you were
born to stand out Justice for fitting in
like it's a very you know low pressure
low stress life
and not everyone can stand out let's be
real yeah and also like you don't want
to stand out in every Department you
know no that's so true it's like
embarrassing like you know but I think
you pick one or two things that are like
you're saying
I love that thank you mclart so what's
your thing
where do I begin it's your place
I think honestly like my thing where I'm
like above average and like I stand out
is obviously like Looks Beauty Grace
um but actually like it's personality
which is just sounds like a euphemism
for ugly no but I'm not I'm not happy I
don't think there's so many pretty funny
people
yeah no I definitely think like my if I
have to ever like lean on my talent my
talent is my personality like Charisma
like I really am like I'm not weird in
social situations that's my thing I I
would say what about you I agree with
you that's your thing
yeah
you oh what is mine I'm saying what
about you oh what about me not what do I
think your thing is no not us having a
hard time communicating today no I
figured what's your thing
um I think
I think Reese I think recently my thing
is my brain
not to say I'm like so smart but I think
I'm just like a
a thinker
you know I don't think brain means smart
I think it means um like curiosity yeah
a thirst for knowledge interesting
interesting yeah
um yeah I think your brain like if I'm
having a conversation with someone like
I'm gonna rely on like what I know and
what I want to know no I think that's
that's very smart of you I agree thank
you Matt Clark look at you using your
brain once again
so we've got a great show a really
promising endeavor
I concur since I chose the stories and I
feel good about them so oh God what do
we have today Royal this Royal that
Royal this there's actually only one
Royal story today and it's about the
Princess of Genovia and I think
everybody wants to know about it oh I do
yeah so without further
oh not to get off track again but like
what happened with your Taylor Swift
tickets are you going to the show oh I'm
so glad you brought that up here's the
thing I don't want anyone to worry about
me
um because I will be going you know I
I'm in a position where it's like
whatever it takes like I will I will get
there and I'm very fortunate so what
you're saying is whatever it takes takes
it through no I've literally been
singing the Degrassi theme song since
yesterday but here's what happened me
and Margo both registered for verified
pre-sale I didn't get it but Margo did
which is all we needed
exactly at 10 o'clock yesterday we get
online we're in the queue for probably
three hours it froze you're not supposed
to leave don't leave don't leave we were
halfway through when it froze eventually
hours later we got through and we got to
the thing and there's one literally one
ticket in the back I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this
and there was like a couple on the floor
all the way in the back and Margo just
wanted to like pull trigger and get them
but they were like expensive and that's
not what I wanted like one thing about
me I'd rather be in the stands in a
lower row than on the floor in the back
row yeah you know I think it's a very
delicate balance I think like making
hasty decisions the floor there's no
incline
yes I know and Margo was like anything
on the floor I'm like no actually like
I'd rather be in like row four in a good
section with a riser then row 50 in the
floor except that she does come out into
the floor we both got floors for
reputation tour and we had a ball okay
exactly reputation tour I spent
literally every dollar to my name and I
was in the second row on the floor like
yeah that's
that's worth it in my opinion but
spending like a thousand dollars a
ticket that's what it was after taxes
and fees to be in like row 30 on the
floor Margaret was like let's just get
it and I was like No And I hesitated and
then they disappeared and then she
blamed me but I stand by what I did also
like can't you get tickets yes so here's
the thing going I'm gonna let me finish
my sentence not like because I don't
want to say because you're like you know
famous or whatever
um can't you just no that's not what I
was saying no but that's what maybe
someone would have thought I was about
to say can't you just buy tickets like
it's a regular concert you know the week
before the show StubHub there's gonna be
take bad tickets good tickets expensive
cheap like everything
yes so I will not be concerned so today
I am going to go again for the Capital
One at two o'clock
um
and I'm going to try and again if
there's not seats that I want like I'm
not going to buy them first of all I'm
not going to take tickets away from
somebody who would actually want those
seats and I would be like begrudgingly
purchasing them and two yes like just
like any other concert there will be
tickets on StubHub people already
started putting them up for like
seventeen thousand dollars that will go
down we're still like eight months out
from the first show so just keep that in
mind
um it will go down I'm gonna try again
today if I don't get what I want I'm
just gonna wait and I'm gonna be like
trolling resale sites and if that's what
I have to do that's what I have to do it
sucks and I could complain about it or I
could just be a grown-up and just do it
yeah
and so that's what I'm going to do
I will say you know
like I understand because I'm also like
deeply and toxically obsessed with
Taylor Swift like probably to a level
that is unhealthy but some of the
behavior I was seeing yesterday like
people sobbing like seriously they lost
a loved one that they couldn't get
tickets at the queue I really think like
people are not okay like it was so not
normal some of the tick tocks I was
seeing like I couldn't get it and it's
totally sad and like I feel for you but
like we need some perspective you know
there are people that are dying
hmm
so just keep that in mind like I wasn't
I wasn't happy I'm gonna persevere and
I'll end up with the tickets that I'm
meant to get because you will Bloom
where you were planted you will it's
beautiful and you know what if I don't
get pre-sale tickets like I'm not able
to pay face value I'm glad someone else
is because you know what I can afford to
pay a little bit more like let's be real
so if someone else gets it and not me
it's okay
it's beautiful
and I trust me I have tried using all my
connections to get like free tickets or
like like it's not a thing like trust me
like I try to be like annoying like hey
yeah like I'm a girl with no job nobody
cares
nobody cares
you need to see so thank you for asking
for an update I hope everyone got the
tickets that they wanted yesterday or
today or tomorrow you know what we're
all in this together and it's gonna be
okay it is and everything will like calm
down I'm sure there the people I don't
think a lot of scalpers got her pre-sale
tickets that's not what's on
Ticketmaster I think it's like real fans
who realize that they got something
great and then they're like how much
would someone have to pay me to not go
and see Taylor what what money would I
have to make and then they're like okay
17 000. if you want to pay it so I won't
go but those people were really gonna go
people were really angry at Ticketmaster
one because like what did we all sign up
for we all got a number in the queue
like you did all these things to prevent
a crash and it literally crashed within
an hour and two like how is it that like
all these real fans are still waiting
for tickets and resale sites are being
flooded with with resale tickets from
people who are clearly not enormous fans
I think it's a combination of people
being like yeah if someone would pay me
17 000 this is capitalism I you love to
see a small business owner getting out
there
um but I do think a lot of it is also
like scalpers and Bots and it's like how
have you not been able to prevent this
right how is that possible
but it's like a lot like Ticketmaster
has really um
kind of shady uh uh intentions because
they also own
like a like resale market so it's like
they also stand to benefit from the
resale market
so it's just a little shady like it's
literally it's giving Mafia for real
I mean and I can't even blame Taylor
because like as an artist first of all
you have literally no choice like
um most of my shows are sold on
Ticketmaster and like Live Nation and
those there's nothing you can do about
it there's nowhere else to go first of
all and you have no power you need them
so you can't even blame Taylor yeah no
I'm not and I mean even though this is
annoying for her fans like it's just a
testament to her power so it's like
power it's bittersweet for her I'm sure
yeah but yesterday she was nominated for
a bunch of Grammys so she like all
everyone is literally we're burning down
stadiums people are screaming throwing
up tweeting and Taylor's comes on
Instagram we're like oh finally an
update because we're all sitting here
Frozen in the queue she goes so honored
to be nominated for programming and it's
like we're happy for you girl but like
we're not okay
yeah I forgot the Grammy nominations and
stories do you want me to Adam oh yeah
okay of course
okay without further adieu it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of something delicious for
breakfast maybe it's maybe a pancake
maybe it's toast maybe it's toast in
which case you would hear this
[Laughter]
today's episode is brought to you by
Caraway homes non-toxic cookware and
bakeware collections it's time to ditch
the chemicals and join Caraway homes
non-toxic cookware and bakeware
collections so that you can make
healthier cooking a piece of cake
Caraway homes non-toxic Wares good
kitchenwares are all designed for the
modern home and they feature a chemical
free ceramic coating so food can be
prepared with peace of mind that know
hard to pronounce compound will leach
into your healthy ingredients all sets
come equipped with easy access storage
solutions so that no stacking is
required gone are the days of misplacing
your lids and it's a big day you guys
because it only happens once a year
caraway's cyber season event is almost
here where you can save up to 20 on all
Caraway products including their
internet famous non-toxic cookware set
for the first time ever you can now save
on caraway's food storage the tea kettle
and the mini cookware so this is the
biggest event of the Season you know a
lot of savings are coming up put Caraway
home at the top of your list of things
to shop if you've been meaning to invest
in like new cookware if you hate your
old ones if they're all missing Lids if
they're all like covered in grease and
burnt eggs Caraway home is the brand of
your dreams they're consolidating these
sets there's no need for like a 16 or 40
piece set anymore Caraway home has four
piece sets that are literally going to
cover everything that you could possibly
need and they're non-toxic they're made
without any toxic materials like pfas
PTFE pfoa or any other hard to pronounce
chemicals they're easy cooking the
surface is naturally slick it means
minimal oil or butter and you'll get
slide off the pan eggs and easy cleaning
visit carawayhome.com to take advantage
of their cyber season event and score up
to 20 off your next purchase of
non-toxic kitchenware the deal won't
last long so visit carawayhome.com shop
all their incredible products for up to
20 off this holiday season Caraway it's
in my home it's in Jackie's home it is
so good for clean cooking it is so good
for storage and stacking if you live in
an apartment like I do like you don't
have time for a million pieces and a
million Lids like it's just premium
carawayhome.com you guys Caraway is
everything if you are in your Homemaker
era it's so key also with the holidays
coming up like it makes cooking so easy
it makes cleaning so easy because
everything slides right off it's actual
magic and a lot of these non-stick
things have toxins in them Caraway is
non-toxic so it's checking every box
it's an amazing
excuse me
first story Grammy nominations who'da
thunk
here are some of the nominations and the
biggest categories this year for the
2023 Grammys
record of the year
don't shut me down by Abba easy on me
Adele break my soul Beyonce good morning
gorgeous Mary J Blige you and me on the
Rock Brandy Carlisle featuring featuring
Lucius woman Doja cat
Uma
kind of the record of our year yeah the
Heart part five Kendrick Lamar about end
time lizzo as it was Harry Styles
so I firmly believe of course everyone
is you know deserving but I do think
this will be the year of Harry Styles I
think his music was quite literally
everywhere
um
it's great music it really was the song
of the year about Dan time is like a
right behind like I do think that also
could win but I do think this will like
Harry Will sweep the Grammys is here
he's like he's been nominated in the
past I don't even know if he's one but
he's never really
had this like major he's never had his
Grammy's moment I agree that I think
that this year is it and I I don't know
if Grammys does this intentionally
probably not it's probably coincidence
but I feel like every year is someone's
year you know and they they win in the
few big categories but that makes sense
if they're the best in one then they
should be the best in all
and I agree I think that it will be
Harry's here and I think that it should
be Harry's ear me too last year it was
lizzo and Olivia Rodrigo it was like
every award was just like lizzo Olivia
already go lizzo before that it was like
Billy eilish everyone really it I feel
like that happens at a lot of award
shows like this is my favorite reference
you can add it to the list of things I
always talk about but Slumdog
Millionaire like when they were at the
Oscars like it was every single award
they were nominated for it was a sweep
um and that doesn't happen every time
but I do think this will be a Harry
Style sweep I think it's very deserved
this was the year of Harry Styles he
works incredibly hard his music is so
popular it's so Global
um he has amazing sales like it's it's
gonna be the year of Harry I agree I
actually feel like recently maybe in the
movie categories they're doing like this
thing where each movie
we're all winners and yeah just like a
big fat sweep you know like two because
that's really gentle generally
physically what is the creme de La Creme
that means cream
yeah I agree and that's generally like
as a culture like
that's usually what happens like in
culture one thing really like takes off
every year
um and I just feel like I couldn't go
anywhere or open any app without being
confronted with a song from Harry's
house and what was so crazy was like I
was just like busy when his album came
out and I feel like I sat down to listen
to it maybe two months after it came out
and the way I literally already knew all
the songs because I just been so
familiar with them from like Tick Tock
from social media from commercials like
it was really ever on the radio so I
think that constitutes album of the year
yeah well here are the nominees for
album of the Year voyage by Abba 30
Adele un Verano CNT Bad Bunny
Renaissance Beyonce good morning
gorgeous Mary J Blige in these silent
days Randy Carlisle Music of the Spheres
Coldplay Mr morale and the big steppers
Kendrick Lamar special lizzo Harry's
house Harry Styles okay I feel like the
only person who actually might compete
with Harry is Bad Bunny
um hold on
bless you oh I sneezed on it it's true
oh my God not me literally predicting
the Grammys
um because and see I don't know what the
Grammys constitute like the Grammys
obviously like is an American award show
um but Bad Bunny literally is probably
the biggest Global artist in the world
um and I don't know if that means
anything to the Grammys because like the
recording Academy is very much like an
American thing
I don't know I feel it it has to count
for something I feel like also Beyonce
is going to give him a run for his money
yeah yeah even though I personally
really enjoyed Renaissance I didn't see
it like when I when I think of Grammys
for album of the year record of the year
I I think a lot a huge part of it is
like did I see it everywhere like on
every social media and with Renaissance
I actually really didn't like there was
break my soul like was her single and it
was like a good single and it was
popular it was on the radio and then I
feel like other things from Renaissance
like really didn't get picked up the
only thing there was like one Tick Tock
Trend
um
you should it's like a dance that I
tried to do and it's so embarrassing
like to dance because there's something
I'm thinking of but I can't remember
we getting [ __ ] up tonight
you don't cease what should you see that
you you and me it's literally one dance
move but it's like you need to have
actual Rhythm to do it
um and that's something a lot of people
don't possess and it's like
people have been doing the dance and
like it's actually become like a funny
thing where it's like we're just really
like applauding people for trying
because it's such a simple dance but
it's so complicated I gotta check it out
send me the clip yeah you know who did a
really good one Ashley Darby
killing it on Tick Tock by the way I've
seen some of her stuff
I love that for her song of the year A B
C D E F U by Gail and Co you're kidding
me no that's like a b c right
f u and your mom and your sister and
your job and it's insane that's like 10
Things I Hate About You being nominated
yes it's exactly the same genre you know
what song I heard recently because I on
my new running playlist it's all this
like teenage angst Tick Tock tumble brag
oh yeah I went for a run
um twinkle twinkle you know that one
twinkle twinkle little [ __ ] why you're
such a narcissist narcissist no it's
literally like cringe music I like it
but I can't believe it's grammy-worthy
no that's insane yeah about damn time by
lizzo and Co All Too Well 10 minute
version Taylor Swift and Liz Rose as it
was by Harry Styles and Co bad habit
Steve Lacy and Co break my soul Beyonce
and Co easy on me Adele Adkins and Greg
Kirsten that Adele having a last name
so true that's crazy what's Madonna's
last name I don't know imagine it's like
Cohen
lift shits God did DJ Khaled and Co the
Heart part five Kendrick Lamar and Co
just like that Bonnie Wright only Bonnie
Wright
you hate to see country not getting into
the song of the year so I went to a list
of snubs of this year and there are a
lot of snubs country as a whole was
snubbed in the big four categories
Morgan Wallen is uh super snubbed yeah I
think people would have thought that
wasted on you would have been nominated
in some of these categories yes
um because when you look at the numbers
and you know Kanye loves to say
you they say you got to sell it to smash
the Grammy Grammys really cares about
like streams and sales that's like a
huge Factor when they're deciding on who
to nominate and what whatever you think
of Morgan Wallen you actually can't
ignore the fact that like he has the
biggest numbers like in the industry
like it's like he's breaking records
same with Luke Holmes like country has
really blown up because of the two of
them in the last couple of years they're
like two of the biggest artists in
country but also like really in America
like they're doing Stadium tours they're
playing the same venues as Taylor Swift
that's bigger than like
Selena Gomez Katy Perry you know what I
mean he's bigger than a lot of the pop
girlies and I feel like they're
constantly being ignored and it's crazy
yeah also Nicki Minaj was snubbed and
she had spoken yes a few weeks ago about
how they were putting her song in the
pop category instead of the rap category
right which was already it's not but she
wasn't
um
she wasn't even nominated in pop
one thing about me um also on my running
playlist
one thing about Nicki Minaj and I've
been like a hater in the past is like
she is talented like she actually
genuinely cannot make a bad song yeah no
I'm like I'm obsessed no I'm I'm
actually obsessed new artist always an
interesting category and there's a lot
of snubs and wait just back to that
sorry for song of the year prediction
like I do think it'll be between lizzo
Harry and Taylor Swift like Taylor's
like when you think of song of this it
should be all 2L 10 minute version sorry
like that I know you just think of the
song that's like always on the radio
always at the clubs and like all too
well is a song that people sought out to
stream and watch on YouTube like by
themselves it wasn't like consumed a lot
in public do you know what I mean also
it's a 10 minute version it means it's
three times better than all these other
songs it's it needs to win I'm not like
I don't want to discuss the other songs
can have their opportunity in other
categories
agreed it's like not my problem you know
the other songs can try Sears it's not
my problem where they decide to get
their joy and they're so true it's like
not our problem
new artist Anita Anita Omar Apollo Domi
and JD Beck Mooney long Samara Joy Lotto
main skin Toby oh this one has a
pronunciation
Toby Nui gay Molly Tuttle and wet leg I
I haven't heard of any of these like
except for a few and I do think it'll be
main skin except for main skin because
they're from Euro
Vision Eurovision and they're the
winners of Eurovision and honestly we
were watching Eurovision and I was like
who are these people I would like I
don't even remember their performance
they have blown up especially in the
states which is crazy because I think
they're Dutch it's really
um it's unprecedented and I do actually
think they deserve to win yes also snubs
for the new artist category according to
billboard which actually did a pretty
good snub and surprise list M behold
Dove Cameron Gail Tate McRae Lauren
Spencer Smith
okay wait that's such a good call Tate
McRae the thing is it's like
the Grammys are are really interesting
to me and and Gail was nominated for
song of the year with abcdefu right
um but the Grammy is like I'm very
curious like how much of a part Tick
Tock plays in the Grammys obviously it's
a contributing factor but like Tate
McRae Lauren Spencer Smith they're
Tick-Tock artists like obviously they're
now expanding beyond that but like
that's what people associate them as
more so Lauren Spencer I feel like Tate
McRae has kind of evolved a little bit
out of that but both of them are
Tick-Tock girlies and I'm curious like
how much of an impact Tick Tock has on
Grammys they have to consider it I think
that it's it's one thing just like radio
is one thing just like streaming is one
thing you know just like concert ticket
sales are one thing I think it's just
one thing yeah also I think snubbed Mimi
Webb is my best new artist of the year
Mimi web is really not that big in
America that's the only thing and that's
why as America you're LARPing in Britain
like you're not in New York right you're
not in Florida right that's why it's
Americans we're gonna be falling behind
right because we're on the global stage
Mimi Webb we're sleeping on Little Mix
and we continue to stay asleep and it's
like I'm awake over here no on the
global stage it's like embarrassing as
Americans I hear you yeah best pop solo
performance easy on me Adele I think
Adele is not going to win very much I
don't think she's gonna even come yeah I
feel like you know when it could be your
year and you know when it's not and I
don't think artists huge artists really
are going to waste their time going I
actually think Adele might go because
like she's kind of going to everything
recently like she's oh that's true she's
out and about she's very available
and she lives in L.A she got that I'm
telling that she bought there's a party
down the street sure why not sure and
she loves a good time I think she can
appreciate the other people who win
whenever she's like gone and someone
else wins she's so happy for them like I
feel like that's just like the energy
she's been putting forth I think if
Beyonce goes Adele will go because like
Adele is obsessed with Beyonce yeah
Moscow Mule Bad Bunny woman Doja cat bad
habits Steve Lacy about Dante and lizzo
as it was Harry Styles I don't really I
don't like really care about the
particular genre categories because that
just feels like people who couldn't make
it in the of the Year categories but
when you just go to Country really quick
yep on my way
because I want to know who billboard had
as a snub I feel like there's probably
ones I didn't even think about
country solo performance heart first
Kelsey ballerini something in the art so
good something in the orange Zac Brian
in his arms Miranda Lambert circles
around this town maren Morris live
forever Willie Nelson
where the [ __ ] is Luke Combs his album
he's in country album of the year he is
in country song of the year with doing
this and he is in country duo group
performance without running your memory
with Miranda okay okay but his album
should have been nominated for album of
the year it's my album of the year I
agree I agree so this category is really
interesting
um because I feel like I feel like it
might be like an underdog situation with
Zach Bryan are you into Zach Bryan at
all where is that the one that you were
just talking about no that's Tyler Tyler
Childers but like it's the same Vibe
okay
I discovered them both on Tick Tock Zach
Ryan is so cute he's a Swifty and I'm
like 95 shira's girlfriend is a toaster
like you just absolutely love to see it
um and he's just like insanely talented
and his music is so good and it's it's
like this it's the last time I was
talking about Tyler Childers I was like
struggling to explain what genre he was
it's very much like folks Bluegrass Vibe
I kept saying alternative and that's
like not it like folksy bluegrass music
it's just it's country but like really
stripped down
um and it's really beautiful and he has
like this cult following and I feel like
he could because there's not like an
obvious winner to me in that in that
country category because Luke Combs and
Morgan Wallen we're both snubbed and
well there's a bunch of and that's the
country solo performance yeah he could
win
that but I just feel like it's gonna be
like Willie Nelson or something
totally like they don't know how to rate
country music sorry no but they don't
they should really bring in some some
gorgeous Jewish Consultants no and it's
like and that's and we're obsessed with
countries so that's what I feel about
country I'm sure everybody who's
obsessed with other categories are
feeling like they don't know how to rate
their categories either so true you know
I think that's the frustration with the
Grammys right there so true
um country duo group performance Wishful
drinking Ingrid Andres and Sam Hunt hate
that song yeah it's not as good as it
should be considering the two I think
that's all are wonderful I agreed
midnight writers prayer Brothers Osborne
I love them but I don't even know what
song that is me either out running your
memory which is it period everyone go
home you guys and all too well it's the
best song it's literally the best song
I'll run in your memory card like you'd
love this Barn
[Music]
I sound like good right no but this is
the best part ready because you've been
right here in this truck's in San Antone
like not me going to San Antone you know
girls trip girls trip
um does he love you Revisited Reba
McEntire and Dolly Parton I'm sure
they'll win even though no offense never
heard of it never wanted that girl Carly
Parson Ashley McBride great song
that is a great song going where the
lonely go Robert Plant and Alison Krauss
oh Alison Krauss is like a country
Legend but who's Robert country album
let's talk let's talk growing up Luke
combs for me this is it done everybody
go home it wasn't gonna happen for you
this year maybe try next year no maybe
you should try releasing music like a
year maybe that Luke Combs is taking off
because if you're gonna be in the
category in the running with Luke Combs
like you are gonna lose Sweetie okay in
our hearts and Minds at least for sure
yeah you're all you're all losers to me
Palomino Miranda Lambert
we're actually an amazing album I
listened to a lot of it as she McBride
presents lindville Ashley McBride it's
hard for me it's hard for me to root
against Ashley McBride when I so deeply
love and respect her and you're her
number one fan right I'm her number one
fan and I just want to say like she's so
underrated she's so talented Martha diva
man
Martha divan
you put your hands on the wrong damn man
this time
so good humble Quest Marin Morris
you know not my favorite Baron Morris
album and I'm really like a I feel like
I know all of her music and I didn't
even get into this one like more than
once agreed and a beautiful time by
Willie Nelson
okay like
sure
next is country song
so circle of the Year circles around
this town Marin Morris and Co
good song but I don't think of the year
and also I I mean I'm sure it's the
single and it's one they put forth but
like I don't even think it's the best
one from the album
I thought it was really good like a
great country Bop doing this Luke Combs
yes done how to have a Friday night
Crayola
cup of brown look a couple buddies no
honestly I know I say all the time like
I would take a bullet but when I really
think about it like I actually would
take a bullet for Luke Combs because
you keep doing what he's doing the world
would Suffer Without him if the world
would Suffer Without Me too but like on
a smaller scale I think and I would I
would lay my life out on the line for
this man okay but I'm about to
switch things up for you because also
nominated is I bet you think about me
Taylor's version
oh [ __ ] okay this is a thing I can two
things can be true they're both amazing
songs but when I think about country
song of the year to be honest neither
one of them to me are actually the songs
of the year I feel like doing this
doesn't even get played on the radio do
you listening
yeah where
in the radio there's no more country
radio station in New York
yeah it's so true Justice for 94.7 Nash
FM like bring it back I'll literally
I'll do an hour I'll do an hour yeah
Chef em you should donate your fortune
to bring back Nash FM as like Public
Radio Service quick question what
Fortune are you [ __ ] talking I'm just
saying like in the hypothetical
conversation of like okay you're Jeff
both the lottery you have 100 million
dollars and you're doing the giving
pledge like where are you giving all
your money you know what I'm giving it
to Nash Nights Live I'm giving it to New
York country music education
I'm gonna bring I'm gonna give it to the
Nashville
um Country Music Hall of Fame Taylor
Swift education center for them to open
up a branch right here in New York and
the branch is in my living room yeah so
you're donating to the Arts you're a
patron to the Arts one thing about me is
I support the Arts okay let's finish
this country song of the year if I was a
cowboy Miranda Lambert and Co I'll let
you till the day I die Willie Nelson and
Co and Cody Johnson till you can't
um honestly I don't feel like any one of
them was like the biggest song in
country this year no me neither not that
I know what the biggest song in country
is but also billboard had said that um
Cody Johnson till you can't was passed
over for song of the year and should
have been nominated based on like
popularity
I don't even know it you probably
wouldn't I don't you can't recall it but
I'm sure I would know it if I heard it
Cody Johnson is like one of those people
who are like it's real country it's not
that pop country crap they play on the
radio like Cody Johnson is like the face
of like real country and people are
obsessed with him I know nothing about
him but they call him kojo and I think
him and co-host should get together and
write a book 100 in a sexy country book
oh I kind of love also it's worth noting
unloading this billboard article um no
country album has received an album of
the Year nomination since Casey
Musgraves golden hour
and I just want to say I know it was
like it was a really bad year to be
giving nominations out to Morgan Wallen
but his timing for that Scandal could
not have been worse because his album 30
the the dangerous the double album was
the biggest album of the year in terms
of numbers streams sales and he would
have gotten a nomination had he not been
like you know blacklisted from
everything also it was the biggest album
in terms of length uh it was like 100
songs but that doesn't that doesn't
automatically no I'm sorry you could
have released an album of crap if you
have more fire songs it's better than an
album with less fire so not not to say
that's why he should have been nominated
but it's like commendable that he
literally put out a hundred fire flame
songs there's no steps there's no skips
on that album or me I agree
um that was like a really tough time to
be like into Morgan Wallen music and
then like you saw this and you're like
oh my God I can't listen but like you
were like the music was really good so
it's like hard to stop listening you
know yeah
I feel like
um
he's probably had to make peace with the
fact that like these sorts of of
accolades like are not going to be
coming his way and he has to just you
know either continue on or not
um I don't know if that'll change but I
think we're very much still in like the
ignoring Morgan Wallen phase country is
like very slowly led him back and he
goes to Ward shows he doesn't really win
stuff and I think he gets nominated now
but doesn't win in categories where he
obviously should I'm not sure did he
perform at the CMAs this year
no
um they're very much like keeping him as
at Arms he doesn't seem like the kind of
person who would care so much about
industry stuff like this but I imagined
for him it's like okay you know what
that side of things isn't going to
happen for me but then he sees like
other people who have committed like
worse crime said worse things and they
get their you know uh
they take their Hiatus and then they're
back like nothing ever happened and and
he's kind of like stuck and he's like
why at its core I think that's
fundamentally the problem with like the
whole you know scandals and
cancellations is because it's really
people get treated Case by case
differently some people it's just based
on the timing of when things happen the
scale how many people actually care it's
oh like it's different
punishments for different people and
they're not always equal and they don't
always make sense so I think
fundamentally that's what's the problem
with cancer culture because like if
we're going to cancel everyone like
everyone gets the same same punishment
for all but some people there's just
like amnesia
and yeah some people just forget and
it's like oh you were accused of sexual
assault I never heard of that or like
you said this thing like you just it's
like oh a heavy do you remember that
totally no it's so people it's like the
lead headline in every article right
like you cannot bring their name up
without bringing up their scandal from
however many years ago mm-hmm it's
interesting so I will be watching the
Grammys I happen to really enjoy the
Grammys
um because I'm a patron of several
different genres and I'm obviously of
course hugely influential on Tick Tock
and so I know a lot about music yeah you
really do so the Grammys are February
5th feels like a long time away but yeah
it does the nominations are here okay we
need to move on to our next story which
is a little more music news because
there's like something going on between
Drake and Taylor Swift
yes okay so Drake posted the Billboard
Hot 100
um which he has totally taken over with
his new album her loss and he has eight
out of the 10 spots on the Billboard Hot
100 he has numbers two through nine
number one is Taylor Swift number ten is
Unholy with Sam Smith and Kim Petras and
he posted a screenshot of the Hot 100
and he put emojis over Taylor's name and
Taylor's song and said uh 21 Savage
congrats my brother because they took
over the list but he didn't block out
the other non-drake 21 Savage artists
and people were speculating that there
is definitely some shade there then
Drake's producer also seemingly shaded
midnight
um he took a screenshot on his own
Instagram and wrote the world knows what
the real number one song is hashtag
richflex no tricks on this side
so so I guess that Taylor of some tricks
so what um what song was number one
anti-hero and T snitches hero
yeah so I guess the beef is that they're
accusing her of like either you know
doing something to keep her spot on the
number one chart I don't really feel
like Taylor's had a place in her life
where she needs to do that and it sounds
like Drake is just a sore loser
um
and this is not cool because one thing
I've always really liked about Drake is
like his relationship with Taylor I feel
like it was like a year ago that he
randomly posted a picture of them on
their Instagram he deleted it obviously
like recently it's not there and I saw
recently I saw yesterday the picture is
gone the pick is gone
um beef is there's beef stew in the
Caraway it's a chillant there's a
chicken for Shabbat that's not good I
like Drake my Jewish King
um but Taylor
and you know Protestant Taylor is the
queen of my heart body and soul is she
Protestant I don't know but I was just
like making a point like even though
Drake is Jewish Like I Do stand with
Taylor
got it
you know who else does Protestant
the queen Queen Victoria
can Queen Elizabeth
um this is just I hate like reporting on
something where we have literally no
information but there's beef and that
sucks but can I ask a question can I ask
you a question
have you ever yes I didn't forget the
lyrics and I've tried to put them out of
my head because they're weird
um
and
how is it that last week Taylor took
over the Hot 100 with so with all of her
songs and then this week only one is
still in the Hot 100 when I feel like no
less swifties are streaming the songs
well I think it might not have to do
with like less swifties but it's like
now Drake has entered the chat yes but
okay sorry but even the music number 10
being Unholy like
where where's midnight
no that's a good call and
anti-hero I guess it's getting on the
radio so that has something it's a
single billboard but like we're all just
listening to the whole album no that's
true but like billboard those charts are
like so Antiquated because they like
still it's like radio AirPlay so so many
of those things contribute to what makes
the number one single and that's that's
Taylor's game like Taylor all these
artists have very much like moved on
from like the old school way of dropping
music and like radio hits radio singles
Taylor does it the old school way
because these things like billboard like
they actually matter you know what and
and maybe I'm also just like a pop girly
so I see Taylor stuff but then I look
right
um Grammy nominations for song of the
year and like if it wasn't a single I
don't know it
no it's true and like you forget like
the way that you feel about like pop and
country there's literally millions of
Drake fans who feel that way about Drake
and don't [ __ ] with Taylor Swift so his
new album entering the category it makes
sense why you cut out a lot of her yes
that makes sense to me but number 10
being Unholy didn't make sense to me
when you know that she had one through
ten
a mere week ago and a mere week ago and
I can't imagine I'm the only one I was
barely listening to Midnight's whereas
now this week I'm listening every day
well I think most people have the
opposite experience I feel like the
longer it's out the more you listen to
it like if you're like a real like die
hard fan you know oh my God he's so Emma
die hard for Taylor
you are I think in the skip like ski
through the lens of The Big Bang Theory
I am yeah through the lens of you and
Margo I'm a hater no yeah and that's on
you're so negative perspective
100 are you ready for our next story
I really am some Christmas drama legal
news Mariah Carey has been denied the
queen of Christmas title in a trademark
case
Mariah got a lump of coal in her
stocking before the holiday this year on
Tuesday the U.S trademark trial and
appeal board ruled against the pop
Diva's legal attempt to trademark the
name queen of Christmas it was also a
real ruled that she can't trademark the
titles princess of Christmas of
Christmas or qoc for queen of Christmas
either the decision means that the Regal
holiday monikers can still be used by
another singer Elizabeth Chan right who
says she's the world's only full-time
pop Christmas recording artist well her
and Michael Buble but Elizabeth who has
put out 12 albums of Christmas music to
date has also used the title princess of
Christmas as a nickname for her daughter
and sometimes collaborator whose name is
Noel I think this woman is obsessed it's
the queen of Christmas yes Mariah was
attempting to trademark the queen of
Christmas title via her company called
lotion LLC to use on a line of
merchandise that would include albums
fragrances pet accessories sunglasses
and more but Chan filed an opposition in
the case earlier this year other singers
such as uh Chris Miss baby please come
home singer Darlene Love also objected
to Mariah's move and the attorney who
wrote Chan said in a statement this was
a classic case of trademark bullying we
are pleased with the Victory and
delighted that we were able to help
Elizabeth fight back against Mariah's
overreaching trademark registrations
Elizabeth told page six quote I did this
to protect and save Christmas Christmas
isn't about one single person it's about
everybody
you know what she's a hundred percent
right
Justice
for that and and I and I want to say I
agree with Elizabeth like there really
can't be one queen of Christmas and if
there had to be it would be Mrs Claus
and so the fact that like everyone's out
here kind of forgetting about Mrs Claus
is hella disrespectful yeah and she
stays silent on the matter because she's
not someone who would like get in the
mud she doesn't want to be a polarizing
figure she's literally the queen of
Christmas for all right and like she
doesn't have to prove herself as the
creative Christmas you know like this is
like something who are her last name is
to be the queen of Christmas but this is
so true Mrs Claus has it in the bag also
of course all I want for Christmas is
the best Christmas song of all time
period
there's nothing to be said after that
agreed
but
one Christmas song does not make the
queen of Christmas because if that was
the case then I do think you know who
else could throw her hat in the ring as
the queen of Christmas it would be Miss
Kelly Clarkson of course
but then one day
everything changed
underneath the tree literally people who
hate our singing episodes like this
episode not for you you know who should
stay away today people who hate singing
and The bigfooted Toasters and the
Grinch because it's extremely festive so
true
so
Christmas for all sounds like justice
was served and the American legal
judicial system is finally doing its
thing yeah I think that's pretty cool
it's pretty pretty cool and Mariah can
still be the colloquial cream of course
queen of Christmas
agreed but
so can anyone who wants to be
agreed agreed
our next story is really crazy and I
know that you're gonna have some strong
feelings
Jana Kramer says that she was ghosted by
Chris Evans after he smelled her
asparagus pee on a date just listen to
The Story So Jana Kramer has a podcast
and Chris Evans we know Chris Evans was
named sexiest man alive uh last week as
we also know and so she opened up on her
podcast about her brief romance with
Chris Evans about 10 years ago and how
things between them soured after a very
embarrassing bathroom incident
she revealed that she agreed uh sorry
she agreed with the choice to me the
sexiest man alive and then talked about
how they met at a club when she was 26
and went on a few dates more than 10
years ago she said he was definitely
known he wasn't Captain America but he
was the heartthrob cutie I can't
remember how many days it was I just
remember the last date she said one
night Chris invited her to his home in
Studio City to hang out with his friends
she said it was a fun time but I was
getting a little sleepy and so I was
like I'm gonna go to bed I had asparagus
for dinner that night so I went to the
bathroom and he immediately went after
me and so that's the last interaction
that I remember is him going into the
bathroom after I just went to the
bathroom with asparagus pain she said
that she never heard from Chris again
after leaving the next morning and she
called her exit the asparagus Walk of
Shame she said I don't remember cuddling
that night that's always been in the
back of my mind whenever I think about
or see Chris Evans or Captain America
and I'm like I had stinky pee
okay that's actually really funny I know
um I thought it was gonna be like she
did something disgusting like but no he
used the bathroom after her which is
just like genuinely like a [ __ ] rude
thing to do like wait a minute [ __ ]
like it's just like it's just something
kind of gross and you know Studio City
you have a big house like use a
different bathroom totally
totally I like find like whatever Jana
Kramer's in the news it's like her
podcast she's like fighting with her
husband or something like she's like
they're not together anymore you would
never know you know what I mean
no it's just like she's kind of become
like this like click baby like kind of
like annoying and it's made me honestly
just like find her annoying but I have
to say this story is actually hilarious
and relatable and truly warmed my heart
totally and so real and it's like
imagine for 10 years every time you saw
Chris Evans like on TV on a magazine
it's like oh money but asparagus I I do
think like you know she should have
known better
um being you know even the possibility
of I don't maybe she had asparagus and
she didn't know Chris Evans was gonna
ask her out the possibility of knowing
Chris Evans means you never eat
asparagus like she should have known
better in that sense but you know we're
all human and we all make mistakes yeah
who knows if she ate it on the date or
before and then he invited no even if
she ate it before the fact that she's in
the you know I'm dating Chris Evans
means no Chipotle no asparagus like
we're eating clean we're eating green
we're eating healthy like okay but yeah
there are things asparagus is clean and
green
oh [ __ ] you're right no but asparagus is
known you know it's like so are beans
but you know if I'm going on dates with
Chris Evans even if I don't even if it's
Tuesday and I have a date with Chris
Evans on Friday I'm not eating beans
greens asparagus I'm not eating any of
that [ __ ]
agreed I'm literally eating lettuce and
this is an unfortunate event
that she has since dm'd him I think like
since she's been single she didn't say
whether or not he responded I kind of
ship but kind of but like honestly
they're two they're too different now
like because of her podcast and her
marriage like she has been kind of put
into like a z-list category and he's
very very A-list so I don't think it's
gonna work
yes I hear you but I raise you one Wells
Adams and Sarah Hyland
Nick violin January Jones how come only
how come only the men
of Lester Fame get to be with a list
Gigi Hadid and Taylor not Taylor Tyler
Cameron yeah how come only that was one
man of lesser Fame
get to hit a bit that's true and I was
saying yesterday how like if it's a men
a man of luster Fame no woman of luster
Fame yes also let's see if we could
choose on One Tree Hill like that's
pretty cool no Friday Night Lights
and I need you to never utter those
words again and move on
lights that's pretty cool move on
move on okay anyways um I thought that
was a great story I did them fine I
think they're sharing and this is what
podcasts are for I just wanted to say
this is why the art of podcasting was
invented and why celebrities should have
podcasts to share with us lay people
funny celebrity anecdotes such as this
I also think it's kind of disgusting of
Chris Evans to like have a powder room
that doesn't have like a febreze or a
candle like I just think that's as my
people would say it's not respectful
it's not nice Chris is advocate here it
was over 10 years ago he's a bachelor in
Hollywood like you'll be happy if he has
a fitted sheet on the bed
no he's a bachelor in Hollywood but he's
also like a rich actor with like
housekeepers and interior designers get
a candle get an incense Chris is
advocate here this was before Captain
America you know he was doing
what's your number a few movies here and
there yeah he had plenty of money he had
money but maybe he was saving because he
didn't know how his career was gonna go
saving up so you can buy a candle but
you could buy a whole house okay
but what if he has a candle in his
bathroom but it wasn't lit because
nobody hadn't made a duty yet and would
it have been better if Janna lit the
candle and signal to the party
that there was a smelly situation so
here's what you do if there's a candle
and you made a smelly thing you take the
match
you light the match and then you blow it
out and you drop it in the toilet and
flush because the sulfur from the match
will get rid of any smell and then you
wait like 30 seconds so that he doesn't
walk in and smell match no but it smells
like match and then at this point match
smells like Duty because people only do
that when they make a duty match does
smell like Duty
like when I smell a match I'm either
like ooh birthday cake or ooh Duty
it depends you can tell the difference
because it has a different smell when
it's blown out immediately versus when
the wax has a chance to melt also no am
I smelling a match in the bathroom or am
I smelling a match in the kitchen also
matches fire on wood birthday is fire on
wax wax it's different you're right
different smell so my final question is
would you rather Chris Evans thought you
made the duty with your match
or asparagus p
you know that's actually really
interesting because if you thought I
made a Duty with my match he'd be like
all right she poops like everyone else
but she's a lady who cleans up after
herself and lit a match if he smells the
asparagus bee he might think there's
something wrong with me like I have you
know some condition yeah
that's why because it's so unnatural
that's why you shouldn't use the
restroom
yeah no eating or drinking for 48 hours
before you see Chris Evans yeah
sometimes you have to learn things the
hard way agreed over the final story a
little Royal news
Miracles have been once in a while when
you believe
Princess Diaries 3 is in the works at
Disney and Hathaway is not yet confirmed
however she has said in interviews that
she is down to clowned as the princess
she'll do it she'll do it she'll like it
and she'll do it okay so Disney is
returning to Genovia for a third
Princess Diaries movie it's not clear If
Anne will reprise her role however she
has expressed interest she said uh quote
I would more than entertain it I'm
pulling for it if there's any way to get
Julie Andrews involved I think we would
make it work Andrew's involvement in
Princess Diaries 3 is similarly
ambiguous plot details haven't been
confirmed but the threequel is expected
to continue the story in The Princess
Diaries and the sequel the Royal
Engagement rather than rebooting the
series so it would be same settings and
characters good good you know princess's
daughter
ugh going to high school in San Fran the
Princess Royal yeah no I think this is
fabulous and is very much like whatever
the opposite of flop era is and is in
that era people are just like obsessed
with her there was a you know a couple
of years where she could have done the
three quill and like we would not have
been into it also like the timing is
really good because I feel like Princess
Diaries is like made a Resurgence in
recent years people like are even more
obsessed with it it's been like it's
been enough time that it's officially
like in the archive like the Hall of
Fame of iconic movies and I think it's
great I think this is great I think Anne
would do great and I'm looking forward
to it I think that if Anne and Julie
Andrews are in it there's no way that
it's anything short of wonderful and
hard quality so I have the utmost
confidence
yes I think this is might just be one of
those situations where we hear about the
reboot for 10 years Allah Legally Blond
three
um like the script is being written it's
being cast where's the [ __ ] movie
Barbie
at least I saw a picture of Barbie being
filmed
yeah but maybe Legally Blonde is a close
set it's supposed to come out in May
we'll see about that yeah
yeah
um so I think this would be great this
would be great we need to get a big
calendar in the studio yes of all the
projects of like the dates that they
said we could expect something wicked
and then we follow up when we inevitably
don't get it I love that yeah maybe I'll
do it on the flamingo wall like in front
of me so I can see like one of those
whiteboard calendars
love that
um I also love deer toasters which is
Our advice segment that we do here every
Wednesday if you ever want to write in
the email address is deertoesters
gmail.com it is always Anonymous it is
always your name is kept out of our
mouths so it is a safe space feel free
to write in and we've got some great
um ones today that are brought to you by
Missouri with the holidays approaching
you're probably building your gifting
list majority believes that you don't
have to overspend to treat those that
you love the most majority designs high
quality fine jewelry that you can live
in and style your own way so I've been
on Missouri for a while I feel like
Lauren Elizabeth introduced me to them a
few years ago
um and their pieces like a really dainty
and trendy and cool and classic but
they're also made of like legit high
quality materials and I feel like their
prices are really reasonable and really
affordable so it's a great gift to get
to someone to give to someone because
you're really giving them like a
long-term piece of jewelry that's made
really well that's high quality made of
good materials and this year Missouri
has curated gift guides with something
for every budget and every recipe from
responsibly sourced Diamond Hoops to
recycled 14 karat solid gold rings they
offer in-store and virtual styling
sessions for expert gifting and stacking
advice and 60-day returns during the
holidays which is great because giving
someone a gift is great but also giving
someone a gift that they can return is
even better you know because you're
really at this point just giving them a
credit it's like just go have fun
plus Missouri drops new Styles every
Monday so you're guaranteed to find
something unique for everyone on your
list or you can treat yourself I love
that because it's really
um it's tough to like not buy someone
the same gift that like every single
person has and you want to be unique and
you want to be different but there are
only so many things you can buy for some
one person
um and Missouri is constantly dropping
new Styles every week so you can really
ensure that no one's going to have what
you have your pieces unique it is Iconic
and 60 day returns just in case
with shiny gifts for everyone Missouri
is where lists come true simplify your
holiday shopping and go to missouri.com
m-e-j-u-r-i.com all right dear toasters
are you ready for our first uh
submission yes but add majority to the
toast approved holiday gift list because
it's like that gorgeous gold look of
jewelry and it's a great price point but
it's good quality stuff
strap in because this one's a doozy my
pee drum husband and newly converted
toaster found out last week that his Dad
aka my father-in-law is dating someone
he hasn't really dated after his divorce
so we're still getting used to the
thought of seeing him with a new woman
so fast forward to Saturday morning at 7
50 a.m I'm on my phone scrolling through
Instagram when I get a text notification
from my father-in-law to my husband and
I without thinking I opened the text
message and to my horror it is a very
explicit sex clearly meant for his new
girlfriend I didn't realize it at first
because it was a long message that
started with I just woke up from a
rather sensuous dream about you with a
blank word that rhymes with election
and I kept thinking I was misreading the
words my brain truly couldn't comprehend
my father-in-law realized right after
sending and started texting and calling
me my husband lied and told his dad that
he deleted the message from my phone
before I woke up so as far as my
father-in-law is aware I never saw it
he's coming over for dinner next weekend
and I don't think I can look at him the
same my husband had my husband never had
to read the text because I warned him
before he saw it and as mentioned my
father-in-law thinks that I never saw it
so really I'm the only one who's
panicking over this face-to-face
interaction I don't think I'll be able
to act normal help sincerely a very
traumatized toaster
um I don't know I feel like the
situation was genuinely handled
perfectly your husband whose actual
father it was didn't have to see the
message and then your husband protected
you from the shame of your father-in-law
knowing that you saw it sounds like a
perfect situation you know and not an
ideal situation but handled perfectly
and you're like looking for things to
complain about yeah nobody knows who
knows what which is the best case
scenario in this instance and honestly
the person I feel the worst for is your
father-in-law like nobody feels more
Awkward than the person who sent that
and I I'm happy for him that he that his
son didn't see it and that he can think
and believe that his daughter-in-law
didn't see it so maybe he can find some
peace in this incredibly traumatizing
situation and yeah for you like you're
you have to shoulder this one and you
have to deal with it but thankfully it's
not your our blood and right it's okay
for you
no this is ideal honestly when I read it
I was like oh my God your husband
covered for you your husband's a pizza
I'm like
literal Perfection I don't know what
you're seeking advice on how is she
gonna handle dinner knowing that he had
an election
you'll be fine like how do you think
your son was born I mean how do you
think your husband was born like old
people they're gonna [ __ ] your son too
you're gonna [ __ ] your son too if you
have one I don't know but like
people [ __ ] don't be mature like it's
fine
no because I'm sorry like there are
people with real problems this is not a
problem no it's just like a little
awkward but you know what like keeping
it interesting no please think about how
much worse it could have been like for
real yeah you could have seen a picture
could have been you could have seen a
picture penis in your inbox big penis
and a big chin in your inbox your your
father-in-law could be walking around
knowing that you saw it and he doesn't
know that so like I think as much as
this not ideal situation could be
salvaged it was
and we all just need to move on you
could have borne witness to the election
you could have could have gotten the
election results and you didn't
yikes
so always think how this could be worse
that's always a great way
to make your problems seem bearable
yeah
all right next up this one is really
unique and I feel like we've never dealt
with something like this and it it's
tough okay hi Jackson Claude first of
all I love you ladies here's my dilemma
I've been with my fiance for six years
now we have a baby together he had been
previously married and is now divorced
but his ex still uses his last name they
were married for five years but here's
the thing she never even legally took
his name she is now also engaged to a
new man and has a kid with him as well
this bothers me so much especially if
I'll be taking his name when we get
married it just makes me feel like I'm
Number Two like how is everyone okay
with this my fiance asked her about it
years ago but she just said it's an
easier name for her students to use
she's an elementary school teacher by
the way every time I bring it up to my
fiance he brushes it off but honestly it
bothers me so much even now like she
needs to let go of the relationship and
his last name am I crazy for thinking
she needs to stop using his name Juma I
get my fiance to approach her about it
how is her new man okay with this
all right here's the thing it would
bother me a lot too but she's engaged so
just wait her name should be changing
imminently right and if it doesn't
change when she's married to her new man
I think her new man would be upset but I
would also just ask like
does she do other things that make it
seem like she's not loosening her grip
on your man like is this just one thing
among many or it's like you guys have
really nothing to do with each other
each other she's just this other woman
in town who has your last name like
I feel like you
generally speaking like you can't
control what other people are gonna do
you can only control your reaction to it
and
if she doesn't change her name when she
gets married or if she stays engaged and
they're just in a partnership and she
never changes her name and she's never
you can't make her call herself
something that she doesn't want to be
called you have to find a way to make
peace with it and not let it bother you
so much
yeah but let's hold on to hope that her
pending nuptials will solve this problem
but if not yes you're gonna have to do
some sort of like inner work to make
peace with it and it's not like your
fault and of course this is frustrating
and
it's it's not like an ideal situation
but if you can't change the facts then
we've got to change how we feel about
them and not let that's true and not let
them have so much control over our
emotions and like have such a proud of
profound effect on us and you don't want
to be like having to go to your partner
all the time like who you love it with
this thing that's bothering you about
his ex who he doesn't think twice about
right but I can also under I totally
understand the frustration 100 in
someone's second wife but like you
really want to prove yourself being like
you know I'm the one [ __ ] especially if
like you live in a smaller town and so
it's like oh the here are the solvers
and there's that other software across
town right and it's like no it would
make me mad
it's definitely like a weird thing to do
if you don't have kids with someone
yeah to get divorced and keep the last
name
no I think I yes it's
it's not what I would do but until she
gets married again like that is and also
she never legally changed it so that's
[ __ ] weird but until she gets married
again it's not like
category five yeah let's just pray she
fixes this issue when she gets married
whenever that is wishing her well I'll
send her a saucer
gorgeous all right our third and final
one I love this one
dear Claudia and Jackie I'm a 36 year
old single toaster I've had two serious
live-in relationships both have ended
and I'm now living alone I have a great
apartment a steady job and I find myself
at a Crossroads I'm thinking more and
more about about having a baby on my own
having a family is so important to me
I'm not getting any younger and I think
this might be the best option for me I'm
wondering if you can weigh in do you
have any friends who have done this
Jackie as a new mom can you imagine
doing this on your own I know this will
change my life forever and won't be easy
especially financially but I don't want
to miss out on having a family of course
I will discuss this with my friends my
family my doctor but I thought I'd throw
it to you girls as this idea is in its
initial stages and I'm wondering what
Pearls of Wisdom you may have
I just absolutely love this idea
um I don't think like sometimes in life
like your timeline is just not gonna
work out like you always think like I
want to have a man and then get married
and be married for three years and then
have kids and sometimes life just has
other plans for you and the one thing
that like unfortunately as a woman like
is very time sensitive is your
biological clock and I love that you're
thinking of this and honestly I do have
friends Brian just did it he
is 39 and he was like you know what
everyone thought you know you have to do
this and he's like you know what I'm
just gonna do it he's so I saw him last
night he's so happy and
yeah of course like I think he he was
saying you know he's this while this
child doesn't have like a traditional
mom I want you know a million aunties
like there are things you can do and I
think you know what don't let
the timeline
let you miss out on something that's
really important to you so I'm all for
it yeah
it's such a big question like it's not
really like something I'm just gonna be
like yeah like it's a huge commitment to
do that I I'm so for it if that's what
you want to do like it obviously is
a lot of work and even with two people
and it's even more so with just one
person so I'm not gonna minimize that
but I think that having kids is like the
most amazing thing and if that's what
you want like you should
do it and you should have that and have
everything that you want it's it's a lot
and but that doesn't mean that it's not
worth doing and unfortunately like even
as times change like for women our
bodies don't you know there's things
that you can do you could freeze your
eggs you could wait longer hopefully
meet someone maybe like then have a
surrogate but who's to say that that
would would happen you know so if like
and those you know are such expensive
yeah so if you're in a place right now
where
you've like you feel ready and you're
prepared to do it on your own like I
think that's amazing and I wish you all
the luck and well wishes in the world
but it does it takes a village and so I
don't know and I don't know like your
life but like and or your village but
just
be prepared but right oh no that's good
advice just based on what I like what
she shared and I don't know like the
whole picture I would say do it
um yeah but also then keep in mind like
you're now probably for the next three
years I think safe to say like dating is
gonna have to be on the back burner for
you like because of course you're gonna
be a single parent and the first couple
of years are hectic
um so also keep that in mind yeah also
I've heard of stories of people who like
who go this route and they ha and they
make their own family and then they find
the right person and together you know a
whole family and everybody has different
paths to
they're happily ever after and so I
think that taking matters into your own
hands and and knowing what you want and
starting a family is like the most
beautiful thing that you could do so I
am yeah like but just and then when it's
a big one
it's a big one but then once you have a
child and like then you start dating and
the guys who like want to be a part of
your family like you're attracting like
the most wholesome energy like you're
attracting like family oriented people
and I feel like I love that yeah because
even if you I love this learning
tomorrow who you thought could be the
real deal you wouldn't have kids for
years for years and we're we got clock
we gotta go we got clocks so so I think
it's so great that you're being aware of
that because
at least for me like I refuse to think
about it you know
but like I don't know her I do not know
the clock the clock knows you and the
clock knows no I don't think she does I
think she missed me yeah she don't know
me and I hate her and I just I I think
that if like having a kid is exactly
what you want to do I think you should
just go for it I agree with you know a
lot the knowledge and understanding the
knowledge and understanding of what
comes with it but you're also never
really prepared even when you think
that's true you know it's
it's a lot for everyone so I think
that's wonderful and I wish you all luck
and I I hope we get an update one day me
too and you keep us abreast of your
journey we're here for you I mean
remotely you've had our support
100 and that's huge
and that is also our show so thank you
guys so much for listening to the toast
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so at Spotify
iTunes District public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places so
everybody listen to podcasts find us the
toes and leave a five-star review about
how wickedly talented we are reminder
that our holiday collection of merch has
officially dropped at toastmerch.com
sweaters pajamas ornaments mugs blankets
slippers all the things toastmerch.com
don't miss out there is limited
inventory and we will see you tomorrow
bye bye